somali soldiers stormed the home of a
british is commander operating in this
remote region he fled into the gal gala
mountains but not before recruiting and
indoctrinating fighters the first
evidence of the so-called Islamic state
reaching the Horn of Africa the man with
the bright orange beard as the commander
Abdul Qadir Moumen a UK passport holder
who lived in South London and still has
links in the country here he and some of
his supporters are pledging allegiance
to is having split from the Somali
al-shabaab group the propaganda film is
filled with urging x' to their fellow
Muslims in the rival group to join them
in the much better funded global is
Network it's a tempting message of
better prospects in this desperately
poor country in the village of gal gala
where the is commander had his face the
Somali military is now in control but
the jihadists left a trail of
destruction burning and trashing homes
and terrifying the citizens for the
women it was particularly harrowing they
told us about regular beatings and abuse
for not covering themselves up enough
this was just something like a mob they
just pull you out recklessly they throw
you around from one man to another while
that is happening they hit the hit you
with the whips
we were given a military escort for the
seven-hour trip into the mountains
Somali intelligence fears the twinning
of al-shabaab terrorist with is is an
alarming development and suspect the
involvement of a handful of British
Somalis as well as some funding from the
UK the key is containing the new is
branch here and stamping out sleeper
cells further south this has got to be
one of the most difficult landscapes in
the world to secure not only is it
hugely inhospitable the soldiers simply
aren't here in enough numbers they don't
have good enough equipment they don't
have enough money and they've got this
vast area not only to defend but to
clear out the soldiers have been
fighting the homegrown al-shabaab terror
group here for years but is with its
global reach and international funds is
a different prospect altogether and the
soldiers were keen to show us a robust
response to any suspected jihadi
movement is repelled the soldiers can't
risk them spreading outside this
mountain region senior commanders told
us the international community ignores
at its peril the emergence of is in
Somalia and the autonomous state of
Puntland if Puntland is not helped to
fight terrorism there will be a breeding
ground for terror here that will spread
to the rest of the world these weapons
draped and the jihadi flags much favored
by eius were seized during a recent
attack from the sea many of the fighters
were very young and to the security
services is and al-shabaab with s
similar ideologies and objectives are
indistinguishable
we're one of the few who've been allowed
to talk to the child soldiers captured
and now held in prison in the Puntland
capital of Garraway the eldest is 15
the youngest only 10 he told of being
kidnapped and forced to fight and what
happened when he tried to flee the
terror group do you think he was
fighting for us
did they tell did he was were the boys
told what the purpose of the fighting
was the authorities insist these boys
will be rehabilitated but they're part
of a new generation of fighters being
ruthlessly exploited by competing jihadi
groups and now the International is
Network has put its tentacles down in
the Horn of Africa how many will be
coerced or tempted to join with the
promise of paradise and riches